la carretera está desierta
ruinas de los recientes combates
ensucian el camino
esta pequeña ciudad al sureste de
jarquín ha estado atrapada en el fuego
cruzado durante semanas
[Música]
escondiéndose de las bombas miles de
personas siguen viviendo bajo tierra
[Música]
a
400 personas se apiñan en esta red de
bunkers la mayoría lleva viviendo aquí
desde los primeros días de la guerra
entre ellos los ancianos casi 80 niños
qué edad tienen 4
denis vive en el búnker con su familia y
nos muestra los alrededores solía
trabajar en una fábrica pero el camino
en este momento es demasiado peligroso
debido a los frecuentes bombardeos
tenéis su extensa familia de 16 personas
duermen en una única habitación
parece seguro aquí pero nada es 100%
seguro si nos van a golpear nos van a
golpear que así sea
y si salimos a tomar aire el bombardeo
puede empezar en cualquier momento da
mucho miedo y es difícil hacer amigos
aquí es muy triste porque todos mis
amigos se han ido al extranjero lejos de
aquí
donde hay
a las afueras de la ciudad se han
llevado la peor parte de los combates
casas reducidas a escombros por potentes
explosiones los soldados dicen que este
enorme cráter fue causado por una bomba
de 500 kilos los combatientes ucranianos
mantienen a los rusos a distancia por
ahora los heridos están siendo
trasladados a un hospital de dziwisz
mientras el sonido de los bombardeos
resuena
[Música]
nos han dicho que lograremos todas las
fachadas del hospital el personal médico
teme los ataques selectivos
no tenemos ninguna opción tenemos que
tratar a los pacientes este es nuestro
deber y eso es todo
mientras las calles se vacían en medio
de los bombardeos de vuelta al refugio
el hijo de denis nos muestra sus bocetos
aviones tanques motivos patrióticos
y esta es la bandera de ucrania
imágenes del conflicto en curso que está
marcando su infancia y que sigue
haciendo estragos justo al final de la
calle